talking about rain yesterday i even had
a couple of like maybe some like light
drizzle
this morning coming into work is it
going to continue tonight i don't think
we're going to have it as active as
yesterday christian yesterday was a big
active day but that doesn't mean we're
completely done for the rest of this
week it's just today
not quite as widespread as far as those
storms go
compared to yesterday we'll show you why
in just a bit live look outside right
now
skies have opened up a little bit we
have partly cloudy skies and there's
some areas that did get showers like
christian said this morning
and some of you recently on the far east
side and down towards henderson
mainly light showers though 98 in
centennial hills 89 spring valley
96 for north las vegas 97 for sunrise
manor whitney ranch and henderson your
numbers have dropped
quite a bit due to some showers are out
there near downtown henderson 95 in
anthem
southern highlands at 94. outside the
valley 99
for prump state line coming at 98
degrees at gene we had a good storm
earlier today right around the noon hour
and then that died out as it made its
way up
towards henderson 91 in searchlight 106
for laughlin so let's get to the
satellite and radar right now we have to
watch what's to the south because again
everything is moving in that south to
north direction
anything that pops up here it has to
stick together hold together
to give us some thunderstorms what
they've been doing is they've been
firing up here yeah
right around state line but they've been
dying as they make their way up towards
the valley
it's still possible we could still get
some storms so we're going to be eyeing
that to the south
to the east we go plenty of storms for
you in mohave county that's the reason
for the flash flood watch there and
there's some
flood warnings in effect right now
lightning strikes detected with these
storms too and that doesn't surprise me
along with downpours so that's why we
have been seeing some flash flood
warnings in effect mainly east of us
in mohave county outside of kingman and
right around dolan springs and
that's been about it all that's
responsible due to that high and where
it's situated it's to the east of us
right now
wrapping around that monsoon moisture
the daytime heating creates a convection
that triggers starts that up
now what's going to happen is this will
pivot down south a little bit more and a
little more
westward later on the week and what
that's going to do is open the door to
more scattered storms
for now though futurecast doesn't give
us big prospects for
showers or storms for tonight not like
last week where we had those nocturnal
nighttime storms
not going to happen this time around in
fact this evening things will stabilize
and we're not looking for big chances
for tonight in fact tomorrow
not really big chances either mainly
east of las vegas that goes for
wednesday two
but by the time we get to thursday and
friday those numbers start to go up even
more
and especially as we head into your
weekend 85 degrees tonight
overnight warm and still going to be
humid unfortunately isolated
thunderstorms
a slight slight possibility and we're
talking isolated if anything happens at
all
104 tomorrow mostly sunny storms will
still be off towards the east for those
of you in kingman
those winds should stay light for now we
could get some outflow gusty winds from
storms
nearby 101 someone tomorrow 103 for
north las vegas 102 for henderson
southern highlands at 103. 101 for
prompt and 111
for laughlin at this hour or i should
say for tomorrow
your eight day forecast does show slight
chances through
thursday bigger chances come friday and
into your weekend
numbers drop and then we're drier
tuesday next week after those chances
for thunderstorms
as a monsoon still around this week and
especially into your weekend we'll have
you more on your forecast
coming up just a bit brian lotta
standing by in the news now newsroom
brian i just sent you a text earlier
and to warn you how humid it is in the
studio
yes you did i believe you described it
as soupy
camel soupy it's very soupy in there is
it still like that
it's a little better our guy our
engineers everybody did a great job and
make it cooler in here awesome
so i had to suffer but you'll be okay
thanks ted moving on from the internal
climate of channel 8